remember all those conspiracy theories about
how Barack Obama was not going to leave the
White House after his second presidential
term was over. He was a, as some said, going
to declare martial law and suspend the 2016
election or he was going to violate every
check and balance that our country has in
order to maintain control.
And then of course, Barack Obama had never
mentioned anything that would suggest he was
going to do that. And he peacefully left on
his helicopter turning over control to President
Donald Trump. And if there was ever a case
to be made for an exception and turning over
control to such a buffoon, it kind of would
have been Donald Trump. And yet Barack Obama
as predicted by any rational, clear thinking
person, very, very peacefully left. Donald
Trump has now retweeted the suggestion that
he should get a six year term instead of a
four year term because he was robbed of two
years from his presidency by the Mueller probe
and he referred to those two years as being
stolen from him, not, I know you're saying,
wait, what's stolen? Not Stolen. Stolen. But
we'll get to that in a second. Uh, there's
this disgusting guy named Jerry Falwell Jr.
He's the son of the late Jerry Falwell, who
in my mind is most known for blaming nine
11 on abortionists and gays and Jerry Falwell
Jr tweeted, and Donald Trump's subsequently
retweeted a tweet, which says, after the best
week ever for Donald Trump, no obstruction,
no collusion, New York Times admits Barack
Obama did spy on his campaign and the economy
is soaring.
I now support reparations. Trump should have
two years added to his first term as payback
for time stolen by this corrupt failed coup.
So first of all, no, that's not constitutional.
And if we care about that, then the answer
to this is obviously no. But secondly, this
is a political statement from a guy whose
church is tax exempt because churches aren't
supposed to be doing politics. Now is doing
politics on Twitter, a violation of the nonprofit
charter that churches have? I don't know for
sure. The legal experts would have to fight
it out, but the IRS should definitely be looking
into this. But Trump sees it and he retweets
it and then he decides to take the idea of
those two stolen years to the next level.
Falwell tweeted that on Saturday night, Sunday,
Donald Trump tweets, despite the tremendous
success that I have had as president, including
perhaps the greatest economy and most successful
first few years of any president in history,
a laughable claim they have stolen two years
of my hour presidency, collusion, delusion
that we will never be able to get back.
The stolen Typo is so ridiculous and so embarrassingly
hilarious that Donald Trump ended up to leading
the tweet. But fortunately we have it for
you anyway, but let's get back to the primary
issue here because I, the, the Stalin Typo
is funny, but there's actually a really important
thing here. Is there a chance Trump will try
to not relinquish control of the White House
whenever this national nightmare ultimately
ends either in two years or in six years?
Nancy Pelosi is now concerned that that's
something Trump will do. Uh, she's concerned
that if it's a very marginal, a very small
margin by which Trump loses in 2020, Trump
will not relinquish power or we'll try not
to. Trump has actually said that the only
way Democrats can beat him in 2020 is voter
fraud. He said he likes the idea of the possibility
of doing president for life in the u s the
way that China has put in place that possibility,
uh, under the current administration.
And we would quote, maybe try it sometimes.
So as I've said before, I believe that law
enforcement agencies of the United States
will not allow Trump to stay in power beyond
his actual electoral mandate period. But every
single person who when Barack Obama was president,
was stoking the fears of Obama's not going
to leave. Why are you now silent? Because
there was nothing to suggest that was something
Barack Obama was going to do. Trump has actually
floated the narratives that he can't lose
unless there's foul play. That combined with
his malignant narcissism and weaponized ignorance
actually gets us closer than Obama ever was
to a situation where the president tries to
retain control beyond when he's actually elected.
But then the most disturbing part of it is
tons of Trump's followers agree that he should
get an extra two years. The most important
thing here is not Trump's misspelling of stolen.
It's stolen. It's not that Trump has actually
floated this idea of, you know, maybe president
for life would be nice and I can only lose
by voter fraud. Trump has a significant number
of these Brown nosing sycophants who think
it's reasonable for Trump to get an extension
to his presidential term. They claim to be
constitutional conservatives. They pray at
the altar of the constitution as if it is
a sacred text. And then of course for Trump,
uh, they make an exception and this may end
up being particularly relevant when it comes
to the statute of limitations on obstruction
of justice. Donald Trump is very heavily incentivized
to stay in power for as long as possible by
legal means, by borderline means or by illegal
means, not that it would be successful, but
he's incentivized to do it specifically to
avoid indictment on obstruction when he is
alone, no longer president.
We'll be talking with some legal experts upcoming
on the show about that and the statute of
limitations on obstruction of justice and
that very important footnote and Robert Mueller's
report. Um, I believe it's footnote 10 90
or 10 91, which says whether or not a president
is impeached for the stuff in the molar report.
That would not preclude or be a substitute
for indictment once the president is no longer
president of the United States. This is the
slide towards, it's this gradual slide towards
despotism or I think better said would be
despotism. Hopefully we prevented, we know
it's what Trump would love. Let me know what
you think. I'm on Twitter at d pacman. The
show is on Twitter at David Pakman
show. We will take a quick break. What a big
news weekend, which I am glad
to be
here
to tell you about.